what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
members of the Rob core we are here
world war hulk now I gotta admit I was
kind of on the fence about this I was
like do I really want to do what we're
Hulk I mean this is before I even
launched the Planet Hulk thing because
I've been experimenting with like Red
Hulk and that kind of thing a lot of
guys really really seemed to enjoy it so
I figured why not just kind of go back
from the beginning from basically Planet
Hulk and move forward up through the
chronology leading us into Red Hook so
here's what we're gonna do for the rest
of this week really until we finished
the world war hulk event which should
probably take us about a week or so I
should take the rest of this week anyway
going into like Saturday what we're Hulk
is going to take the place of everything
except DC rebirth so we're gonna keep
all the DC we worth stuff but like a
classic Marvel classic DC well I think
we might keep classic DC and do like
speeding bullets or something like that
where Superman becomes Batman aside from
that like you know how to kill
superheroes things like that the all-new
all-different marvel day that's all just
going to be one more hole because it'll
give us a chance to get caught up really
really fast and then turn around and go
back to doing one whole video a week you
know leading up to the launch of Hulk
and all-new all-different marvel so
anyway so what we're Hulk is kind of
like this coup de Gras right it's like
it's the magnum opus it's the the final
event of Greg packs run on the
Incredible Hulk and we know that because
after world war hulk was over it was
essentially hercules taking up the
mantle of incredible hope it was really
just like it was like The Incredible
Hercules Hercules being put into the
role there would no only be played by
The Incredible Hulk now that was done
just because of the fact that Hercules
just never really had a place in Marvel
Comics and so model is doing the best
they could it give him a place to stay
the issue is that it didn't last very
long a lot of people didn't really like
it too much and have some cool stories
like chaos war which is insanely awesome
but aside from that there wasn't really
a whole lot to go with there but what
were Hogan YCJA Lee opens up with the
North American Aerospace Defense Command
outpost which is actually in Cheyenne
and this is really cool because of
course when we when we had our planet
hulk event our planet hulk story at the
conclusion of that we had talked about
how the incredible hulk had taken a ship
with his warbound and basically moved or
made it made its way towards the planet
earth and this is them essentially just
realizing that the incredible holders
coming now initially they don't know
it's the Incredible Hulk instead they
just know that is ship now the issue
with this is that it begs a lot of
questions with regards to
you know how people don't know it's the
incredible incredible hole for example
in Marvel Comics they have an
organization called sword the sentient
world observation and response
department and this is literally just an
organization that monitors other worlds
now because of monitors other worlds for
you know potential threats it may not
have just it just something made out of
register the fact that the incredible
hope was there or they didn't care they
just suddenly saw a ship but you would
think that with a ship of unknown
origins heading towards the planet Earth
but somebody would stop to ask a
question to say hey does anybody know
what's going on with that ship right
there because it's big and it's heading
here and we don't know what's on it so
you know the fact that that didn't
happen begs a few questions but at the
very least it was just for the sake of
storytelling but the fact remains here
that we essentially pick up on the moon
the blue area of the moon now this is a
big deal because what this does is this
ties into the existing chronology of the
inhumans back before really back before
all-new all-different marvel with the
Inhumans during Paul Jenkins run on the
inhuman event which was like you know
inhuman volume 2 or volume 3 I think
this was essentially a set of events
whereby Black Bolt had orchestrated a
massive duping he had basically just
duped the Inhumans and tricked them into
leaving Earth and going to the blue area
of the moon and that's where the
Inhumans have been the entire time now
for those of you guys who don't know the
blue area of the moon is this
oxygen-rich part of the moon it's
literally a section of the moon where
you can walk around without any measure
of protection and you can breathe just
fine it's actually a huge talking point
in Marvel like a lot of people have been
there apocalypse has been there when he
kidnapped nathan summers who went on to
become cable or the exponent visited
there a multitude of times it's a huge
staging ground like a huge battleground
in the history of marvel's publications
they always return there in some form or
fashion but the Incredible Hulk coming
here is due to the fact that Black Bolt
was part of the Illuminati because
remember he's waging a war against the
Illuminati here now with regards to
Black Bolt his voice his quasi sonic
scream has varied over time in terms of
how strong it is Marvel Comics there's
been times where it's been shown capable
of destroying planets there's been times
when it's only shown capable of
destroying like a small satellite like a
small planet or a small moon or
something like that in this instance his
voice is if I recall correctly is kind
of in the middle of the ground where
it's not strong enough to destroy a
planet but it is stronger to strong
enough to destroy a moon now when I say
his voice is in the middle
I mean if you were to just kind of
whisper or talk at a normal rate
regardless of what writers do a
regardless of where he's been at in his
publication history if blackboard were
to scream as loud as possible he would
wipe out a planet I mean it's always
been that way like if he screams as loud
as he can that planet will be destroyed
with the Incredible Hulk being here as
soon as he shows up you know when he
tells blackboard like dude I'm gonna
take you out like I'm going to destroy
you
blackbolt simply just kind of whispers
enough and it's a it does enough to
basically damage you know the Incredible
Hulk or the very least it seems like it
does enough to damage the Incredible
Hulk but then we learn and one of the
most awesome scenarios possible The
Incredible Hulk says I didn't come here
to hear you whisper I came here to hear
you scream and I was like this is so
badass because it's just the way it's
done it's just it's insane how cool this
looks so from here it's essentially the
scenario where the government begins to
become aware of the fact that something
bad is happening not only that they have
literally chunks of the moon just
breaking away from orbit and so their
question is what in the hell is going on
on the moon but there's a conflict so
massive that it's sending chunks of the
moon into space itself now one other
thing to keep in mind here and this is
something that we'll touch on a little
bit more as we get into this but Tony
Stark is currently the director of
shield this is after Civil War this this
picks up relatively soon after the
conclusion of civil war so we still have
the initiative the fifty state
initiative where we have a superhero
team in all 50 states not only that of
course we still have the Illuminati as
we knew them before and so it's
essentially this scenario where the
world is coming to the realization that
the Incredible Hulk is is about to
unleash hell and this happens when the
Incredible Hulk broadcasts himself to
the world and what he does is he
essentially tells the story of what the
Illuminati are now keep in mind again
the Illuminati always operated behind
the scenes no one ever knew who they
were no one even knew they existed the
only people that were aware of the
Illuminati were the Illuminati
themselves now this all changed really
they came to life during both this world
war hope event and even more so during
the events of Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers when they were
basically public enemy number one
in the eyes of Steve Rogers as the
director of shield but the idea here is
that the incredible hooks essentially
saying you call the Illuminati heroes
you call mr. fantastic you call Ironman
black bolt of the Inhumans Doctor
Strange you call them humans they shot
me into space they didn't give me a
trial they didn't give me you know
didn't give me a chance to to make any
kind of peace for myself instead they
duped me onto a satellite and then I got
into a ship they sent that ship you know
across the galaxy I ended up a nun you
know going through a wormhole ended up
on this planet called Sekar that was
literally a war world and the result was
that you know while I did form a bond
with whether the hope refers to as his
warbound the fact remains that he found
a life for himself but then a bomb went
off because of the ship as it was
designed by the Illuminati which
resulted in him losing everything he had
and so he gives them an ultimatum and
this is really cool because what the
Incredible Hulk is going to do is he's
going to turn New York City into a
gladiatorial arena it's badass when he
does this he says you have 24 hours to
hand over Reed Richards Doctor Strange
and Ironman or I'm going to do this to
every single person that I find and he
literally holds a black ball now but the
kicker about this this is was kind of
ironic is that not everyone knows about
blackboard again this really changed
during Jonathan Hickman's infinity event
when Black Bolt had detonated the
Terrigen bomb and basically caused a
Terrigen mist to spread across the world
waking up in humans everywhere but the
fact that one of Earth's super heroes
has basically been ripped to shreds by
The Incredible Hulk been pummeled to the
point where he's been absolutely
obliterated is an indication that the
Incredible Hulk is not screwing around
now again keep in mind here despite the
fact that Hulk is talking with a comb
voice despite the fact that Hogue is
talking with a calm relaxed tone he's
pissed
I mean he's insanely angry now he's not
as angry as he's going to be at the end
of the story but at this moment right
now The Incredible Hulk is a force to be
reckoned with the other half of this
equation is with Tony Stark being the
director of shield he immediately takes
off he says okay fine
we've got us we got to find some way to
deal with this we got to find some way
to cope with you Incredible Hulk because
if we don't he is going to tear
everybody apart not only that the idea
is maybe we can rationalize where then
maybe we can talk him down maybe we can
figure out what it is that's going on
and so what happens is Doctor Strange
initially appear so Tony larga says hey
look we need to have a contingency
plan in case things go south we need to
have someone that can basically fought
on our behalf or the very least can go
toe-to-toe against the Hulk and so we do
is they go and they visit Robert
Reynolds now Robert Reynolds
historically has his powers are kind of
fluctuated his powers have kind of
changed you know I have videos on him if
you guys want to you're welcome to check
those videos out but the underlying
theme here is that Robert Reynolds is
one of the few characters in the Marvel
Universe that can go toe-to-toe with the
Incredible Hulk they can stand against
him and so the idea of the Illuminati is
to have Robert Reynolds come to their
aid come to their side and fight on
their behalf the issue with this is that
Robert Reynolds is actually not going to
do that now from here we pick up with
some of the miner who's miner
superheroes really not miner but in
terms of like overall strength in terms
of abilities minor characters we of
course have a Spider Man we have a
she-hulk stepping into the fray and
they're really not fighting here so much
as they're helping to orchestrate this
mass evacuation of New York City because
again you know with The Incredible Hulk
showing back up here terrifies the hell
out of everybody not just because it's
the Incredible Hulk but again because he
has the strength to level the entirety
of New York City and so what we do is to
basically switch over to to Iron Man
Tony Stark now again he's meeting with
Luke Cage he's meeting with Doc Samson
she-hulk Wonder Man Sun and Williams I
mean a lot of these heroes that cannot
just absolutely cannot go go toe-to-toe
with the Incredible Hulk and he
basically says hey look you know he's
going to come here you know but when he
does I'm not going to let him just walk
all over us I'm gonna fight him you know
I'm gonna do what I can to hold off the
Incredible Hulk now again Tony Stark has
his Hulkbuster armor and this is this is
really really important because there
have been a couple moments and the the
Marvel Comics storylines we've seen The
Incredible Hulk go against Hulk buster
this one and original sin original sin I
think did it much much better in the
sense that the Incredible Hulk was at
about the same level as he is right now
doing his role burger Hawk form and the
idea was that he basically mocked Tony
Stark you know Tony Stark won against
the Incredible Hulk in original sin with
his a Hulkbuster armor and halters kind
of laughed at him and said you know his
toys you know Tony Stark always has his
toys and they're always amusing but they
don't stand a chance against you
Incredible Hulk and that's exactly what
happens here try as he might the Hope
Buster armor is able to hold things out
for a while Tony Stark is able to do
reasonably well
against the Incredible Hulk the issue
with this is that what it all comes down
to it Tony Stark just doesn't have it
Tony Stark just does not have the
ability to hold on to it now the reason
for this is because I'm going to make a
really terrible analogy here and and I
hope it works for those of you guys who
were Dragon Ball Z fans you guys know
that in the younger days of the series
Gohan was like this character where it's
like every once in a while something
will happen
he'll just lose his and his power
will just fly off the charts for a
temporary amount of time that's what
happens with the Incredible Hulk here
his world breaker form or at least that
the super angry you know unstoppable
force Incredible Hulk doesn't really
come until like the very end of the
story but right now he's still like
insanely stronger than he's ever been
before he's well beyond the limits that
he's been at previously in his
publication history but as he's fighting
Tony Stark he begins to have these
flashbacks to the time that he spent
with Kai error he begins to have a
flashback to the love that he felt for
her to the fact that he was going to be
a father and to the you know imminent
destruction of kyra when the bomb went
off and this just symptom right over the
edge it really kind of like rejuvenates
this anger that he has and he
immediately takes it a Tony Stark and
starts ripping his uh his his Hulkbuster
armor apart now this is why I say the
whole the world war hawk storyline is so
cool because under normal circumstances
if Tony Stark would it go against the
Incredible Hulk with his hook Buster
armor he'd be able to hold out the hook
long enough that either Banner would
just lose interest and walk away or he
would just not really tire out but it
would allow other heroes did you come
into the fray and talk you know the
Incredible Hulk down or it would allow
the situation to be resolved without a
massive amount of destruction that's not
the case here the Hulk just keeps
getting angrier and angrier and angrier
and Tony Stark just keeps pissing him
off more and more and more until it gets
to the point that the Incredible Hulk
has effectively destroyed Tony Stark's
Hulkbuster armor and just kind of left
honey stark down on his own
to figure out what in the hell he's
going to do not only that it allows the
incredible hope to take Tony Stark
prisoner as his first I guess the second
victim in his campaign to take out the
Illuminati as part of the Earth's
superhero roster but with that being
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end and in the next video we'll focus on
what happens at least I believe it's
next video will focus on what happens
when the Incredible Hulk turns his
attention to the x-men but if you guys
are new here to comics explained but she
got to the subscribe button to become
part of the robb
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and leave a comment down
below let me know what you what you
think about world break about World War
Hulk here I can't talk right now let me
know what you guys think and I will
catch you out later peace